can i tell you the crazy story yeah yeah
i want to hear the story because here's
this this story scares me
so it's 19.99 no it's i'm telling you
i'm timing it because it's like late
2000 early 2001. i'm in debt 49
break up girl
nothing's going right in my life i'm
thinking about going back to the army
i've been out of the army for like a
year and a half
i'm drinking like you wouldn't believe
like i'm i'm trying to break records and
i broke a lot of records in the army but
i'm like i'm going all out right
partying and i'm coming back from
outside the garden of eden or it's
dublin's or
it's a a palace or
one of those
key it's not a
it's not the other one in city of
industry what was that one uh the
century club this is all in l.a but i'm
in hollywood and you live in l.a to be
clear i i did i would never have gone as
east as the century club so it must have
been one of these it was it wasn't
century club so i'm coming up and is it
is it fountain i don't know what that
fountain and last that that whole when
you go this way you hit the five freeway
there's a chevron right there i go to
the chevron it's two o'clock in the
morning maybe three o'clock in the
morning i am
gone okay but i got to fill up the gas
tank okay
and i get out and i see you i'm like hey
and you're gone
look you see literally him
he is
i don't know what you were on but i'm
like dude this guy can't even walk
straight i can't walk straight i'm like
you're good i'm good that was a mess
yeah so that was that was an end of 2000
2001. like [ __ ] i freaking see you
everywhere it's like what's up bro
and then we just went on a separate way
just brought it up for a minute i was
like yeah it was a 30-second
conversation and then i just i left
because but uh yeah that was in late
2000 early 2001 yeah i don't know if you
were partying back then that was moments
before my last trip to rehab
really yeah that was moments before last
trip to rehab yeah and the last one was
the last one that worked that was the
last time what was different between
that one and the other ones
you know i
i i don't really know i think i think
the the difference was um i had been to
rehab
a few times based on like friends
sitting me down or my parents sitting me
down and going we're really concerned
about you and me going like okay i'll go
do what you're telling me to do and
the last time i went i woke up one day
and was like i don't want to do this
anymore this is no longer fun what did
you go to rehab for
heroin
boom yeah not even drinking eating all
that no i never went to rehab for eating
i didn't even know those existed i think
they do i probably should have gone but
that that took a little bit longer i had
to get sober before i could like
actually work on my health and my
physicality and what was well i'm sorry
no i mean
heroin holy [ __ ] what was that like
uh
in the
in the uh in the earlier 90s i was given
vicodin as a prescription and the the
first time i took vicodin i just felt
like
this is my antidepressant this is my
this is this is the state that i feel
more comfortable in and so when that ran
out i got another prescription i
eventually started they had um
you know storefronts in the 90s down
uh near downtown where you could go in
and buy vicodin for like a dollar a pill
in la yeah
um and then eventually it got hard to
buy there so you know you you get
creative and you wind up like well
you wind up finding out that heroin is
just like the best form of vicodin and
and it's much easier to get than vicodin
too in fact so that's how i wound up on
a heroin you're a full-on actor in
hollywood at this point yeah full-on
yeah like not you know
small roles like you're doing movies
hollywood yeah
ethan is is it easier or was it
the the drug connection that had
happened through hollywood parties or
was it no it was outside france you know
other contacts there were no i mean
you know what i'm saying like it's the
influence i'm hanging out with hollywood
i'll try some of this okay let's try no
okay no it's more cocaine yeah cocaine
is probably i don't know what's
acceptable now i've been sober 20 years
so i have no idea what the kids are
doing now and and and i would be
terrified to be entering into drug use
now with the amount of overdoses with
fentanyl mixed in with everything like
that
scares the [ __ ] out of me um
but i never
went walked into people doing heroin at
a party it was it was pretty taboo if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]